I'm Amanda and I live yoga this is your
at-home yoga workout for runners we're
gonna start out with a dynamics forward
fold so you're gonna bring your
fingertips down to the mat bend your
knees enough so those hands can come
down so you're gonna start to straighten
and bend at the knees this is very
dynamic you don't want to have a static
pose here especially if you're warming
up for running so you want to keep the
legs nice and active bend and straighten
a few times like that I'm gonna step
that left foot back and again start to
straighten and Bend that front right
knee warming up the hip flexor warming
up the quad warming up the hamstring
next you're gonna take the right arm up
give yourself a little bit of a twist
here so you can start to straighten and
Bend that leg again now you've moved to
the IT band the outside of the leg and
into the knee few times like that hands
gonna come down left knee taps down you
walk your right foot slightly forward
hand on top of the knee now you're in a
crescent lunge here back foot is still
engaged and toe is tucked
push the knee forwards and can stretch
in the left hip flexor me pushes forward
hips sink slightly down shoulders back
chest lifts right hand can go down to
the matter on your hip left arm up and
over the ear this is going to take you a
little bit deeper in the left hip flexor
a deeper stretch here both hands go down
we're gonna take into a quad stretch
so you reach back with your left hand
grab the top of the foot and pull that
heel in towards your butt slowly release
that most injuries happen when you
release the pose so you slowly release
whatever pose you're in and then you're
gonna walk your hands forward foot goes
forward toes go back chest is reaching
towards your right foot so now you're in
a hamstring stretch here
and it may look a little like this it
may look a little like this depending on
your flexibility and where you are this
stretch is gonna look different for
everybody and start to breathe here just
deep breaths in deep breaths out as you
keep pulling the hip back reaching chest
for it you want to think nose towards
toes I'm gonna rebound that knee bring
the foot down step to the top of your
mat and then switch sides you take a
nice forward fold at the top you can
grab opposite elbows let the head hang
you can interlace the hands behind the
back giving yourself a shoulder and
chest stretch here knees can be soft
especially if you have tight hamstrings
and release the arms and slowly come up
to a standing position just to recap we
started out with the dynamic forward
fold step back into a low lunge then a
low lunge twist we drop the back knee
down for Crescent lunge and we went into
a quad stretch into a straight leg
forward fold
we bent the knee standing forward fold
then we repeated on the left side that
is your at-home yoga workout for runners
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
other fighting weight episodes
you